hello everybody my name is markiplier
and here we got a leap of faith we made
it okay ah [ __ ]
what did that do to us why did we do
that [ __ ] god damn it I don't know what
this is not how I wanted to start this
episode I wanted to go to another level
that would be able to actually solve oh
that would be nice is their own secret
oh god there's no comments either
Oh Hank no no it's a little douchey
admittedly but that's okay so am I thank
you hey how are you ain't gonna be me
that easy [ __ ] yeah okay now we're
going somewhere I don't know where but
we got a 1-up man and that's better than
oh god hello giant nose where am I going
where am I going where am I going I
don't know I hope it's not lava
oh god it's lava oopsies
Oh God hello nice to meet you by the way
hi guys how you doing that last episode
was a [ __ ] a very poor showing a hot
Trixie so it's over here huh
they thought they could trick me it was
a bit poor showing it and I felt bad for
giving up I really did try that I tried
it for a good long amount of time but I
just could not get it I don't want that
ah there was no other way to get it
besides that ooh ooh give keep two okay
never you know what forget you got it oh
it makes my ego feels so much better
where is that gonna send me going going
going nowhere I thought that was gonna
like bounce me a much this is a sad way
that he crouches but I got three one
man's and I beat another level which is
better than I can say for the last one I
could've beaten it but it just like I
couldn't see where the answer was there
was no answer man I should have taken a
bathroom break in between this last
episode in this one damn I gotta go to
the back
bathroom okay but it's fine it's fine
and it's fine oh boy the pulsating
darkness is entering my brain but at
least it's given me a one man let's do
this [ __ ]
see what kind of ship of terror is you
oh oh oh is it a boss fight you I think
it might just be a boss fight blink he's
gone okay that's one day Oh Frick me
holy crap didn't mean it didn't mean it
sorry sorry buddy
wink whoa don't even think about it
okay so what's Ryan it's just a boss
fight which is totally fine I'm good
with a boss fight I'm good into entering
an enemy airship and [ __ ] roasting my
taint on an open fire anyway I'm good
into entering an airship and then
destroying everybody in who's trying to
live their peaceful lives well I just
ruin everything literally okay and
somehow I don't know how they've got
fires shooting out of the bottom of an
airship but when I usually think of a
wooden airship are you my first step
would not be to have the fire shooting
up from everywhere just just my two
cents on the matter Hey what what excuse
me dick hole how about you want to run
that by me again [ __ ] you want to run
the silliest way I've ever said [ __ ]
[ __ ] you don't want to run it by me
again I'm a real tough guy huh
you want to mess with me hold fireball
ain't gonna give me I'm too good food
screw you okay so the secret was to get
on this platform cuz otherwise I'm just
going to be roasted boink there we go
okay so now stay away from all of the
fire stupid to fire goodbye okay you
want to play a point
oh [ __ ] I forgot yep blink
okay easy enough and oh [ __ ] god dammit
god dammit
piss yeah piss give give to me thank you
okay so now that we got this we'll be
able to continue our merciless murdering
of everybody with a checkpoint and a
whatever the hell's in here
yeah it was exactly the same as before
okay so now we're continue on what are
the boss - oh hello do I shoot these at
you I don't know you're giving you're
not giving me a lot of space there big
boy
I'm gonna I'm just gonna keep running oh
look who's making it look who's making
it I should have made that ah fack
oh no strands again [ __ ] whoa [ __ ] you
I got this stupid hammer throwing it
[ __ ]
Oh God why I'm glad that stopped about
to end very poorly for me okay no need
to rush even though Bowser is now
shooting very large fireballs in my jet
[ __ ]
Oh God oh no oh god how did this happen
I don't know how this happened I blame
the game I blame the controller I blame
the game oh god I gotta get through here
with expert tees multis oh god no no no
no no that member that
that none of that okay man that's the
second time that I've I've gotten the
good graces of not being roasted alive
by ramping bombs stop stop stop stop
stop
here's my ride I got it okay this is
fine
I'm okay with this fire right I should
just hurry I should just you know once I
get through that second one I should
just worry I deserve that
no not right there I such a dick bag
about pulling it off come on stop that
you didn't do that last time you're such
a prick Oh God okay okay okay it's fine
it's fine it's fine
got a hurry got a hurry can I make it
through before the time runs out and the
time is actually in the shape of big
fireballs made it no don't do this
yes checkpoint I got it all right I got
a checkpoint a while ago Oh dick it's a
bit prick ish it's a bit it's a bit has
a hint of prick hint of Britishness okay
so don't go immediately now go
ah okay give me this I'm ready
whoever where am I going where am i
doing where am i doing where am i doing
where am i doing where am i where for it
where am i oh I get it
just look at the eyes of death staring
from the bottom of the screen wait what
is this is this right I believe I'm
supposed to go under the ship no that
was not it okay weird oh that may okay
alright I did not know I should have
assumed but I did not knew so we're now
we're gonna have a literal airship
battle okay bring it on [ __ ] who's
shooting fireballs woo hello we were
shooting them oh you yeah you ain't
nobody you ain't nobody [ __ ] oh okay so
I need to get that oh [ __ ] okay so I guy
have to why is this such a prick there
we go that guy's down we'll get in
cornered getting cornered get in quarter
this is dangerous okay you know what oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god why why
why why why why why
oh god I have to get the P okay I'm
assuming the laughing means that he's
invincible zhabin hit him quite a bit
okay got it got it got it got it got it
got it getting down getting down getting
down getting down getting down okay I'm
out I'm out baby I'm out I'm out I'm out
I'm out okay down I'm out I'm out say I
won say I won I won I won baby yeah I
didn't get the one ups for
I didn't know there was gonna be there
all right
oh that was an endeavor that was an
endeavor
ladies and gentlemen out there but a
half way through and half way through is
better than no way through so oh man I'm
gonna take a look at one more I'm gonna
try to do one more I'm trying to
accomplish at least three of these per
episode or else it's gonna take forever
so let's do this yes I love you you gave
me love turned to hate and disdain
almost immediately okay but I got this
okay cool
does anything happen with that oh just
death was gonna await me boink boink
well this ain't good thank you
if it's going to be lost I wonder if I
could have just carried on going through
there you can put coins there that
tricks me into going hey your your your
yeah bro
why I beg to differ point boink quick
okay boink okay boink
okay everything is a-okay we are fine
and I love butts just wanna throw that
out there okay so now it's not gonna be
a prick right nope I was just supposed
to fall down food Anand it
who'da thunk did oh boy HAP poink oh boy
oh boy oh boy thank you
which one of these is the right answer
none of them good oh okay I was about to
jump off whoo I would have been bad all
right where do you lead I don't know
where this is but okay hello
okay okay okay okay Oh am I supposed to
wait until he oh crap oh crap now okay
so I just need to get and this is gonna
take forever if that's what I gotta wait
for whoa hey now you're an all star get
your game on go play make it another one
of those can you dispense another one of
the feathers you please thank you thank
you
cuz I gotta clear him out or else it's
gonna take him forever to get through it
all
oh come on bag of ass I already know I
know I know I know I'm fighting a boss
I'm well aware
oh yeah I was did he die no we did not
die which means that oh yes okay that's
another level down we did it
oh poor bells were giving me the bill on
[ __ ] you I don't get back you fell but
not you guys so thank you everybody so
much for watching I'll get to the rest
of this in another episode but wish me
luck cuz I'm still going strong I'm on
target to get to the end of this in the
right time and I made a world record
there so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you